does this dude in Japan that married a
hologram I'm going to predict the next
big crazy Civil Rights Movement is gonna
be people demanding rights for
artificial intelligence robot lives
matter yes yeah that's gonna be the next
big one because they're going to be
someone indistinguishable if not totally
indistinguishable from humans they'll
say everything you want they'll be very
Charming they will have the technology
to read your pupil size and pulse and
skin temperature know exactly what to
say what to do and people are gonna love
them and we're gonna fight for their
right to have rights and get married and
do that kind of stuff a decade ago a
robot was given citizenship because that
robot's a person right like what does
that mean yeah it's really really
strange